[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm kid Bhd here and
it's getting to be that time of year
again when tech picks up again when we
start to move a little bit faster now
I'm sure a lot of you guys realize that
after CES in January there's a little
bit of a lull where we're all kind of
recovering from that but now it's
getting to be that point where we're
speeding up and we're getting some new
announcements and some new leaks so as
if the current generation of smartphones
isn't good enough already here are the
five best upcoming smartphones to expect
in the next couple of weeks and months
number five is the Moto X 2 or the
successor to the Moto X this one's a
little bit lower on the list because
it's a little bit further off so late
summer for this one so August or
September maybe but this will be the
first smartphone that we see from the
new Motorola after the lenovo
acquisition so we haven't really gotten
a whole lot of information about what
exactly is changing behind the scenes at
Motorola
who's staying who's leaving what kind of
designers are going to stay onboard and
what kind of philosophies will stay
onboard so I mean the Moto X was a crowd
favorite a lot of people like that phone
so it'll be interesting to see how much
of those philosophies carry over into
the next Moto X is what we know about
Motorola is correct then we're not going
to be expecting the highest end phone
ever on paper I mean the Moto X was not
the top of the pile in terms of specs
but for all we know they could have been
working on this phone since the day the
Moto X came out as far as we know before
the Lenovo acquisition so when this new
Motorola flagship finally comes out
it'll give us a better idea of the
difference that Lenovo has made to
Motorola and the direction they're
headed in terms of flagships in the
United States pretty important to
distinguish the difference between the
old motorola and the new motorola and
this new phone is going to help us see
exactly that number four is the Sony
Xperia z2 now this is definitely a
high-end phone and it's already in
existence already people who went to
Mobile World Congress got to see it I
didn't go so I haven't seen it yet but
if you couldn't tell by the name the z2
is the successor to the Sony Xperia z1
that are reviewed and I had my gripes
with the z1 that I talked about in the
review video some annoyances with the
display and the flaps all over the phone
and the Xperia z2 is still IP 58
certified which means it's still dust
proof and water-resistant but it does
have some new improvements to the
display and the build the design the
battery and the specs of course so
there's a lot of improvements behind the
scenes to make this a worthy successor
to the z1 there are also some camera
software improvements so it has the same
20 megapixel sensor as a z1 but it joins
the ranks now of smartphones to shoot 4k
video so the z2 is shaping up to be
Sony's major flagship competitor for
2014 and that'll be out on April 1st
number three is the Samsung Galaxy s5 a
lot of people were expecting a lot from
the stone and it's almost impossible to
live up to the hype we see this with
basically the iPhone and the Samsung
Galaxy S line but don't get me wrong
this is still a very high-end phone so
it still has a 2.5 gigahertz quad-core
processor 2 gigs of ram the latest
version of Android a 5.1 inch 1080p
display it's the whole works but I
actually did get to spend time with this
phone so if you want to check out my
full impressions video of it boom you
can click there for the first link below
the like button and that'll be what I
think of the Galaxy s5 so you can click
that or already could you know click it
later it opens in a new tab so you can
just leave it there and come back to
this video yeah so that phone comes out
on April 11 so number two is the all-new
HTC One or the m8 as we're still calling
it it's a successor to the m7 or the
current HTC One which I'm actually using
as my daily driver recently and lighting
a lot this phone we thought wasn't going
to leak and then we remembered it's 2014
and everything leaks so we got a 12
minute hands-on review video of this
phone comparing it to the one it may not
be the best video in the world but it's
the only video in the world showing this
phone what it looks like in person so
you might as well watch it if you're as
interested as I am so look this phone is
all about build quality and design again
that's what it was all about with the
original HTC one that's when it's going
to be about that's the number one
talking point again for the m8 and it
looks like it's going to keep a lot of
the same design features from the
original one including those
front-facing speakers but with a couple
little quirks about it I mean this this
slightly asymmetrical speakers and the
slightly unnecessary chin but that's
okay because we already know this is
going to be a very high-end phone again
as HTC does and if you want to check out
exactly what to expect I also did a what
to expect video I'll just leave that
link right below that like button if you
want to watch that so we learn very
quickly last year after the one max came
out that it's really all about that one
flagship so we'll find out on March 25th
exactly how successful HTC is going to
look this year so number one is the Oppo
find 7 now this one's a sleeper for a
lot of people but you know I mentioned a
lot of the previous phones plan on being
high-end top-notch flagship caliber
specs by the looks of the teasers we've
seen and what Oppo has shown us or at
least told us about so far this phone
aims to top everything it aims to trump
that whole race it's trying to win the
flagship spec war they've teased a 5.5
inch 2560 by 1440 display 2.5 k
Snapdragon 805 processor 3 gigabytes of
RAM removable storage a removable 4,000
milliamp hour battery and a recently
suggested a 50 megapixel camera 55 0
okay basically the only thing we're not
sure about with this phone is the design
so obviously the fine fives design was
very nice but that was a sealed phone
the fine 7 is going to be an unsealed
phone so really I am very very curious
to see if Apple can pull this all
together into one flagship spec package
it seems like there's so much new stuff
it would be really difficult to pull it
all off especially the new camera rumors
got me kind of nervous
about what to expect with this phone but
I'm going to keep my eye on Oppo social
media as well as all the other companies
I would mentioned in this video and
we'll see I posed new flagship to find 7
on March 19th
so what are you looking forward to most
this 2014 if I nailed it feel free to
give this video a thumbs up but there
are plenty of other phones you could
name the Galaxy Note 4 the iPhone 6 the
Nexus 6 feel free to
let me know what the number one phone
you're looking forward to this year is
in the comments section below and maybe
we'll see some new things down there
either way all aboard the hype train
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next video peace
[Music]